ding-ding-ding welcome back to it's
getting harder and harder to give a [ __ ]
about what I look like every day yeah
you look good yeah
no you know yeah welcome back to the
Jillian podcast this episode is brought
to you by this skim get your day started
with this skin in five minutes or less
you can skim the most important news of
the day just go do the skin th es ki mmm
that's two M's coms last channel Julian
and your email signup it's completely
free and I entered to win $250 Visa gift
card when you subscribe check it out
also Squarespace if you guys what kind
of build the website do a Squarespace
Keanu Reeves does it so you should as
well go to Squarespace comm / - no
Julian to get 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain or just
check out a free trial that is
completely free
hit the link down below to get started
thank you sponsors goosebumps I
personally think you're very illustrious
stock of onesies that you have in your
in your closet has just been waiting
mm-hmm it's whole entire onesies life
for right now because you are rotating
onesies like it is your job yeah why you
have to roast me like that why do you
have to expose me like well first of all
no is accepting you're on-camera and
like they can't see anything they don't
know it could be a cool shirt okay
that's how cameras work oh yeah
no okay close your eyes now now just
listen to the onesie no it's you know
what it's I don't like it I like it I
love the way this guy love the way this
onesie is kind well I mean I think it
onesies don't really serve any other
purpose than what you're using them for
which is we're stuck at home and it's
functional unless you have to pee or poo
I just take it all the way off to be I
just pee and then I switch them out oh
wow I just go and there's so much fabric
that it just absorbs Julien was no water
on the floor that's water
disgusting I'm calling the police
let they said man please stop falling so
I compose and empty the hoes Julian I'm
losing it a little bit too yeah what's
that thing he's being sensitive
I'll put rat you found if he wants a hug
he's satting me you know so funny when I
was little does he know that's a
compliment okay when I was feeding him
this morning you know when you go to
give her breast feeding Julian please
that is so wrong in so many levels when
I gave him his medicine this morning
what do you know when you give him his
medicine and a lot of dogs will if
there's a pill they have they'll spit it
out and they can tell he's in there
because I got a like trick him and
finagle him and when Kermit first got
diagnosed with Cushing's disease I was
giving it to him in peanut butter
because I thought maybe he was gonna be
a dog he had to trick and he always took
it really easy
he was really good about it yeah like I
literally just throw that pill on the
top of his like foo same every day if he
may eat every little speck of anything
in that bowl he could so you just like a
little sprinkle it on top like it's a
little piece of parmesan on pasta and
they eat everything it's a pill it's
naked you don't even have to like blend
it in yeah they're nasty and in fact if
peach eats fast enough she'll get over
to Kermit's bold choice eating the Med I
know I've seen her try and do that
before she gets to it I was little treat
that's cuz she just is a sucking vacuum
she dude this morning so usually I'm the
one who gets up and feeds them but this
morning I slept in and you got up and
fed them and I was a hugging peach and I
was like kind of like half asleep I
wasn't really asleep but I was trying to
be and she makes this noise when food is
presented
even if she thinks it's presented a
sound of it's baby food because she's
like salivating at the mouth and like
shows it like eating nothing just
getting her jaw warmed up and just like
suctioning her tongue it's like this
really
strong and then she's our shivered and I
was hugging her I was really trying like
if she helps me sleep so I was just
talking her and I just felt this like
shaking and licking and just like a
monster like she was transforming from a
caterpillar to not a butterfly a monster
mm-hmm
and that's peaches response to food she
would do anything for food she has done
anything she has done anything and I
have to break things up for her because
even though she has teeth and can chew
she will sometimes eat things so fast
that she doesn't bother chewing or
eating she just she doesn't choke on
stuff
Kermit sometimes chokes on stuff because
he only has three teeth so he literally
doesn't chew but she just eats so fast
that I think she's gonna choke every
time like she might choke scary yeah
she's just like her daddy
one of those bulls where they have to
like work around it like yeah we should
hate it but that would give us enough
time for like Kermit to finish his food
and marbled to finish his video or she
goes over there and tries it every day
two times a day she goes over there she
tries it and then for an hour she's
licking the entire floor that whole room
and sides wall anything might smell like
the entire family will be outside or in
another room and peach is not there and
I'm like peach where are you she's in
there licking the floor everything
trying to spend 45 minutes to maybe get
one calorie burnt meanwhile burning
probably like 50 she was burning too
many calories looking for calories Oh
God
well that's a mood peach burning too
many calories looking for more calories
send nudes stop making fun of me no
that's what you're once he says but it's
noodles yeah so it didn't mean like nude
photos it means noodles because nude is
the first part of noodle smiling me like
that
you want to go on a vacation I would
love to because let's go on a vacation
time last year we were on a vacation
mm-hmm and we've tried as adults because
I feel like I went ten years without
taking a proper vacation like we
traveled to her work we're very lucky
very fortunate to go places that neither
of us were expected but they were you
know for work so you're there for
whatever reason and the majority of your
time there is felt like yeah getting
there ya know doing a walk through you
know getting prepped the day one day off
in the location that you're at yeah but
um for like ten years I didn't take a
actual like week off vacation aside from
Christmas mm-hmm which I would always
give myself you're usually a hosting
family or traveling to see family and
it's not really yeah you don't really
get any yeah
days off you're not driving mm-hmm yeah
whatever um this past year last year
yeah 2019 we decided to actually like
take a week off and we went to Hawaii
and we had booked it months and months
in advance were like we're doing this we
had no idea what we were gonna do once
we got there we just booked it set all
the dates like Ken you know the podcast
our videos just scheduled out breaking
everything and we went and I don't know
what's wrong with me as an adult like
it's a normal thing to take time off
weeks off take destination vacation yeah
it's like so new does I just didn't do
it yeah
and lovey ten out of ten would recommend
and for those of you that do that
already good for you good on you yeah
you should it serves a very important
purpose and it's not just to go and you
know do whatever it's really good for
your it's mentally go home yeah yeah I I
got food poisoning and threw up for
probably like ten hours straight and I
still would rate the vacation instead
out that's how fun it was it was a great
vacation anyway so this year we had this
is the week that we would be on vacation
obviously no but no one is on vacation
right now because we're all quarantined
at home those of us who are obeying
quarantine
and we decided it would be a fun game to
play well I decided on my own this this
was on me
I didn't even consult you I just did it
I was gonna look up some extravagant
vacations Wow
so we can all dream so we could well
let's all go on a virtual vacation
together so you but you will be Kishin
peepee you know move over the one behind
there you you you coming along with us
on vacation so what did you just tell
the move don't worry about it so I have
five we're gonna I made a game out of it
though because I thought it would be fun
to not only like review vacations and
like to decide which one or the other
but I was gonna modify them a little bit
throw a little twist on them you know a
little julienne twist
do you like can I do that no it's
intimidating intimidate my surroundings
you know what I think of what I think
that song that bird that has a paper
towel roll on his head thank you I have
a problem i watch a lot of bird news so
I have five different I guess will say
head to head like vacation matches okay
I'm gonna read you the blurb on I found
it on Expedia it's like an article
written by Lili Rogers about all these
different extravagant extravagant
vacations and what they entail like just
a little a little paragraph it's nothing
like crazy in depth but I'll read that
and then I'll present to you the
modifiers that I have added to those
vacations and then you can choose which
one you want to go on okay that sound
good yeah I mean literally any vacation
sounds great and some of us I guess like
it's somewhat of a vacation cuz you're
at home like maybe you don't have to go
to your desk job in your job so it feels
different from being home back yeah we
would all like to go somewhere yeah so
let's all take vacations together
Victoria just this place I think we had
all like a vacation nice mean babe thank
you alright so we're gonna start in
Aspen Colorado
okay I already don't want to go not all
luxury must be the waterfront variety
and Aspen offers an ample proof though
hotel jerome features a fabulous pool
and it's indoor charms set a spectacular
scene it gives the stunning mountain
landscape a run for its money
speaking of run those at Aspen Mountain
are legendary and appeal to world-class
skiers and celebrities alike for some
what is that word a press key press key
no no ski you want a person for some
repressed ski decadence go for cocktails
and caviar or the caviar cocktail at the
monarch oh and toast to figuring out how
to spend a tax refund with aplomb make
friends with a member or join this is
this is all of these are for only very
very rich people okay okay so we can
roast these yeah or join caribou Club
yourself where you should certainly
splurge on some Dom Perignon heaven on
earth Spa can sort you out if you hit
the slopes or the sips too hard I'll be
hitting the steps too hard probably wait
till I get it these are with curated spa
packages that rejuvenate tired skin and
achy muscles basically they just said we
all have tired skin
wait so doing what these are all just
like beyond a luxury vacation but
they're all pretty luxurious yeah
they're definitely like not your average
vacation I chose extravagant vacations
to choose from so I can just uh maybe I
don't want to go on any well you haven't
heard
even my modifiers or the Finland
opponent here okay sorry selca finland
priceless experiences can be of the
moment or result of careful planning
hopefully you will find both in finnish
lapland
put snowmobiling and animal tours with
Lapland safaris on your itinerary and
there's no telling what you'll see or
feel out on the open snowy land you can
prepare for magical moments at Cox
Lawton slot tenman our Arctic Resort in
whatever form they take from Glu
glimpsing at the northern lights from a
reindeer drawn sleigh or the comfort of
a private glass-domed igloo to skiing
the slopes at Serra selca you will
surely experience extraordinary things
okay ready
so now you're going you're voting
between Aspen Colorado and Syrus Elka
Finland and I'm gonna read you what they
didn't include so in Aspen you have a
private hot tub in your quarters but the
hot tub is a time machine
Julien the ski mountain has a minimum
downhill speed limit of 35 miles an hour
if you go under 35 miles per hour you
will be sighted and you'll have to pay
them more money for going slow also
there is no water to drink only
snowballs lien for Finland if you go out
to watch the Northern Lights and they're
not visible you must summon them with
doing yoga all night can't sleep you
have to do yoga all night until the
Northern Lights up here that's how the
Northern Lights work I'm a scientist
you're required to take a siesta inside
an igloo every day at 2:00 p.m. pong you
have to look at me naked siesta also
every wall of your quarters in your
house is glass and see-through so
there's literally zero privacy so where
would you like to go would you like to
go to the high-flying ski mountain of
Aspen Colorado where there's no water to
drink only snow balls or would you go to
Finland or you have to take naps and
igloos and some in the Northern Lights
with yoga I'm not very bad yoga
I'm not going to Aspen I do not want to
ski period let alone no slower than 30
miles and 35 marks five or not I will
die malfeasance I don't know how to ski
well you can go fast
do you want me to answer your question
yes sorry I will die I'm not going to
Aspen okay I don't care if everyone sees
me naked and if I have to do yoga all
night or maybe I don't want to see the
Northern Lights and I'll just sleep
what you can't you have to do yoga no I
don't you literally have to or else
you'll be arrested fine then I'll enjoy
my siesta naked my glass igloo and do
yoga all night I'll just be a backwards
person and sleep during the day but I
want to go to Aspen go to Aspen I'm not
coming with you and I'm not getting in
that hot tub time machine oh it's hot
tub time machine from the movie hot tub
time machine yeah I got that and also
from the movie Hot Tub Time Machine 2
I also don't want to go somewhere cold I
don't ski I don't do winners well both
of these are cold locations I know I
don't want to go to either of them okay
how about Rochester absolutely not
I would meet someday no can I answer
what if you asked me do you want to even
know the answer I feel like some day it
would be nice to travel somewhere cold
to explore and see stuff I haven't seen
but for right now because I only take
one vacation a year and I just started
last year zero this this year we can't
go anywhere it's still not quite what I
want to spend my money on to go and do
so you hate both of them but you'll
choose Finland I hate both of them but
what about the caviar lounge in Aspen no
not me no excited
no no caviar lounge no caviar no caviar
drinks no what about they have a new
thing it's called caviar to go and you
put it in a coffee cup and you just
drink it like coffee I'm gonna throw up
okay moving on
we are going between carmel-by-the-sea
California versus Tuscany Italy
carmel-by-the-sea California laid-back
California charm meets the pleasures of
the good life in carmel-by-the-sea
what better introduction to the area
then through the grand dame of Carmel
will apply a Carmel oh that's the same
sentence once the palatial palatial
palatial home and salon of local artists
the historical hotel uses classic
Californian comfort with its beachside
location near scenic wineries and hiking
trails you like that
after a champagne brunch and a quick dip
in the pool visit the shops at Carmel
Plaza and treat yourself to some Tiffany
and Co make your way to cush Day Spa
khush day spa for a quick facial or book
a spa package for an afternoon of
pampering before you call it a night let
lab elena
transport your luggage to Tuscany with
handmade fresh pasta and ok more about
the food weight transport why don't I
say luggage it's this transport your
tongue to Tuscany ok that's so weird
that they would say transport your
tongue to Tuscany and then the next
location is Tuscany like what do you
you're making me choose between fake
Tuscany in Tuscany ideas anyway classic
pasta you get the idea anyway moving on
to Tuscany Italy or you could see
Tuscany in person Eat Pray Love your way
through this extraordinary landscape Eat
Pray Love your way through it wit which
is both ancient and fresh all at once
Castiglione del Bosco is one of the
oldest estates in the region and offers
modern amenities and in inviting ly warm
sweets lazily gaze across the Tuscan
hills as you dine in swirl wine on the
terrace of Ristorante Campo del drago
achieve zen-like levels of serenity on
the on-site spas you indulge the sauna
steam bath relaxation lounge and private
garden take a cooking class rent a
bicycle
yes join a wine tasting tour and fall in
love with how wonderful life can be that
sounds nice wait can i before you give
me the modifiers can I just like maybe
react beforehand and give you my
thoughts right here what hell you're
gonna throw me no it's heck it's nice
I'm trust me I'm gone these are good
carmel-by-the-sea is beautiful
have you been there yes but it's on the
way when we go to visit my brother
Julian in the area okay so I think
that's super beautiful but like I said
since it's on the way where we go visit
my brother I'm not sure that I would go
there like vacation it would feel a
little because we live in Southern
California sure it's a little too
similar for me to like completely feel
like I've gone somewhere you know yeah
Carmen don't get on the table sounds
lovely though I would love to go but I
think I would rather go to Tuscany Italy
okay so that's your first impression
yeah it sounds lovely I've never been to
Italy now let me add you some modifiers
what okay okay
so in Carmel you're staying in an
artist's home and the artists whose home
it belongs to constantly tells you to
shut up okay cuz you're being too loud
you know how it's said you can go treat
yourself to some Tiffany Co at the
Carmel Plaza yeah for sure
all of the shops at Carmel pause are
Tiffany Co okay all of them there's not
a single other business there's just
streets lined with Tiffany no that's it
no food that's it
pastas illegal in that County what
happened to transporting my tongue to
Tuscany your tongue will be transported
to jail if you have pasta Oh
so think about another cuisine cuz you
ain't having no pasta and Carmel that's
sad I love pasta well now do the
modifiers for Tuscany remember it said
Eat Pray Love your way through this
extraordinary lens and landscape while
you're on your trip to Tuscany you have
to start every sentence with Eat Pray
Love
okay okay I can do that you can only
consume
out of camelbacks okay totally down
watch me cooking classes that you take
are taught by me okay okay so you're on
board yeah okay
where's the downside rented bicycles can
only fly alright fine they can't ride on
the ground
I won't darlin don't write ammonia
random you go for a rented bicycle ride
that's a bicycle it says it's as you can
it she achieves n like relaxation levels
with a flying bicycle it says alright so
what's it gonna be Carmela Tuscany
Tuscany somebody want some pasta my guy
I want pasta my guy alright so you pick
Tuscany yeah it sounds lovely well done
I would love to go to Tuscany
Squarespace this episode is brought to
you by Squarespace squares face is a
drag-and-drop visual website builder
with an editor that's super intuitive
and 24/7 customer support via email or
live chat you can also join the live
webinar if you're building your website
and you need help on certain
functionalities they're there to help
you with if you've seen the ad with
Keanu Reaves you know that Keanu Reeves
uses Squarespace so does idris elba
they're both awesome people and they
have their websites based off of
Squarespace Squarespace is a really
great platform if you're trying to build
a small business and have a website for
it or if it's just a hobby right if you
want to put your art or your photography
or you wanna you're having maybe an
event and you want to go to a website
for I do a Squarespace it's super easy
you're an event you own all I know I
don't know what that is you own all the
content you put on the Squarespace
platform okay and they can make it look
good on every on every device like an
iPad a tablet a phone a desktop it you
can make sure it looks the way you want
to on all devices which is important
nowadays so if you like to get started
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace calm / energion save 10% of
off your first purchase of a website or
domain Squarespace is wonderful makes it
easy to build a website go check it out
also guys at this skin seven million
people right out
wake up to the skin which is a
newsletter that comes for free to your
email inbox
okay when you subscribe every every
weekday every in five minutes you can
what it does is it makes everything
super concise and easy to digest so in
five minutes or less you're basically
skimming all of the top news stories for
the day so before you even start your
day you've been like briefed on what's
going on in the world without any of the
the fluff that you see all over the
internet when it comes to news this is
just the facts and it's put together in
a very nice palatable way they also
allow you to deep dive further into
certain topics if you'd like but right
now if you go to the skin comm slash
annejulien that's th tsk mmm comm /a
Nasreen that's two M's head into your
email click subscribe it's completely
free that's all you have to do you'll be
subscribed and then tomorrow you'll get
your first skin email and you'll wake up
and you'll be like Tim I'm [ __ ]
educated so quick also when you enter
your email you're also entered to win a
$250 Visa gift card that you can spend
on something for yourself or for someone
else I'm not going to judge you
thank you sponsor thank you sponsors all
right moving on we have three more
vacation contests up next Saint Moritz
Switzerland okay sounds nice if you like
your luxury it's called with Sparkle and
ice walking in the winter wonderland of
st. Moritz will suit you to a tee come
to town during white turf the annual ski
during what a ski drink ski competition
that draws the CREM of elite sports
enthusiasts it's not too many it's not
too many athletic events that deem the
winner King but this is not an ordinary
event so literally if you're a woman and
you win this event you are king
horse-racing aren't gourmet bites and
flowing champagne have made this an
a-list winter destination for decades
reserved a room at bad roots Palace
Hotel where indoor where the indoor pool
has a floor-to-ceiling 180 degree view
of in Gaudin mountain scenes you'll and
you'll also find a hot
water bottle tucked into your sheets at
night Oh
keeps your feet warm a hot water bottle
yeah that's what people used to do for
you like oh so not for drinking no
because I was like why are they talking
water in your bed and also why is it
warm am i right peach before retiring
however wine and dine at the doll mule
in and order a nightcap at the cozy
local favorite polo bar this all sounds
so rich with it's convenient proximity
to your hotel and it's on the premises
that's what it says it literally says
that you don't so worry about if the
bartender has a stiff board all right
that is going against Greenwich
Greenwich Connecticut okay with four
beaches historical charm and a tendency
to attract the affluent Greenwich
Greenwich my brain stopped working long
ago
Greenwich that's pronounced cream it has
to be knows a thing or two about living
the highlife Delamar Greenwich harbor
hotel we'll get you settled into a lush
suite with harbor views order breakfast
book a spa treatment and let everyday
worries become a thing of the past
plan a day on the green at Tamarack
county club I can't read Tamarac Country
Club or take a tour of the bush Holly
house for some local history become a
patron of the visual arts at Flynn
gallery then relaxed with a pint at the
ginger man or craft a cocktail at the
national before dinner at Thomas ankle
Minh I don't know what any of that means
anyway go into st. Moritz so what they
forgot to tell you was wait can I react
oh yeah sorry I forgot guys so there's a
lot of content I'm trying to produce
here so right my first reaction is I
don't want to go either of those places
yeah we know you don't wanna go
somewhere cold I don't want to go I also
like Aspen or a lot of these places I
get so uncomfortable if places are too
nice because I'm not like a fancy people
you know well this whole game is wrong
for you exactly yeah like I have
to go somewhere where I can feel
comfortable because I'm not of fancy
people mm-hmm I feel that so I don't
want to I would like to go to
Switzerland but maybe not the fancy
fancy people part can I go to somewhere
else and why do I have to ski I don't
want to ski well listen you don't have
to ski I also believe that that word is
pronounced Greenwich and I don't want to
go there because I had to go there
multiple times a year in college because
we played them in softball I am
certainly not eating on a plane to go
vacation in Greenwich Connecticut is it
called it must be alright well thank you
well you have you haven't heard what
they haven't told you we beat them st.
Moritz the only thing that's on TV at
your local hotel or the resort is the
ski touring competition you're Candace
that's all you can watch room service is
only ice and no other humans are staying
at the hotel just horses okay that kind
of sounds nice that's a selling point
but so the only room service is ice but
you could get food somewhere else
yeah but not room service and the only
thing you can watch is the ski
competition ok can you bring like
Netflix no because if you bring Netflix
or a laptop you open up your screen and
it's automatically the ski drink allowed
to bring a book no they'll hack your
book no position inside your book that's
ridiculous
well it's my game so ok fine yeah with
Greenwich every restaurant in town is a
Guy Fieri franchise ok it's kind of a
bonus you might be there you never know
I don't know how much we'll be able to
I'm not done all the beaches are bottom
nude you literally will be arrested if
you have pants on you have to be bottom
nude meaning the bottom of your body
can't have clothes you can only eat
dinner
if you golf under an 80 at the Country
Club you have to break 80 and if you
don't you [ __ ] get back on the course
and you break 80 otherwise you're not
eating a lick of food
good luck surviving if you suck your
golf
welcome to Grandma's
if you take the history tour you have to
take a pop quiz and if you don't get an
A you can't leave the museum so there's
a couple of traps I don't want to be
bottom news you might be able to hungry
nah I could probably ace that test but
for what's to go be bottom nude and not
eat anything
oh you can't eat just break an 80 and
then you can have all the guy fear your
food you want that doesn't sound so bad
because at least I have fries I'll go to
the first one you're gonna go to st.
Moritz yeah
so you're gonna only eat ice no that's
not what you said you said only room
service vacations are all about room
service so what are you gonna do no
they're not I disagree I think they are
no they're literally not I think they
are okay I think okay go ahead say all
the guests being horses sounds kind of
nice don't be loud I don't mind
maybe I'll go pet them but they're not
in pens you're in like hotel rooms I
don't care they're not gonna be
comfortable they're gonna be kicking the
walls nice really loud because they
probably order some room service gonna
be watching the ski during competition
at full volume you might get a hose
through the wall at something in the
[Laughter]
vacationing in horse poop oh God
the maintenance crews also horses the
tractor all right fine okay next we have
Park City Utah whether you want to go to
Park City Utah what is with this woman
that wrote this that just we just
clearly wanted to go skiing really bad
it's good there's other places to
vacation what about partners and other
things to do on vacation she I'm gonna
go ahead off on a limb and say that she
might have written this article remotely
from her skiing vacation
Oh whether you come to ski or Explorer
Park City will treat you to either of
those Park City will treat you with kid
gloves or Park City Utah King come here
after an unforgettable day skiing the
slopes are hiking trails you'll relish
some R&R what is on our rack relax and
relaxation the five-star spa offers
treatments such as ski boot relief with
the salt and honey scrub stop you for
one second I'm so tired of her talking
about okay this is all in like respect
like we're roasting this a little bit I
respect this person and what they do for
a living is a joke but I do not want to
ski and I don't care about all these
spas I decided along
time ago I really don't like spas my
strangers touching you I don't like
being touched
that's fine me - me neither I'm a
cold-hearted Virgo and I want you to get
your hands off me cuz I don't know you
we had a couples massage on our last
vacation I had to pee the whole time it
was not enjoyable I mean it just it
wasn't the worst thing ever but I
definitely like I'm not the type of
person who would enjoy that either I
like it if you gave me a massage or like
someone that I know gives me a massage I
don't we'll get to that I don't really
enjoy a stranger's hands just like all
over my body it's very difficult for me
to relax
fair enough and I had to pee the whole
time they offer treatments such as ski
boot relief with the salt and honey
scrub soothing stone massage and the
Aspen Oasis a warm body wrap and rain
bath for a meal to write home about
visit J&G grill will you be treated to
beautiful views and a mind melting
tasting what is he doing menu Fox School
of wine host events such as fine art
whisky and wine or guest invited to
indulge in all three make sure to stroll
down historic Main Street we're shopping
and dining options are prime so that is
going up against Bora Bora Wow French
Polynesia it's not a place to go skiing
when you picture the perfect vacation
the iconic image of thatched roof Hut's
over turquoise waters probably comes to
mind whether you know it or not you're
dreaming of Bora Bora it's a it's home
to such two hotels such as the
intercontinental Bora Bora Resort and
philosopher which fits the bill exactly
you can practically jump from bed into
the balmy waters and you can take a
double dip in the deck pools that offer
that some of the rooms offer continue
you're on water excursion with a private
sunset cruise that features champagne
and dinner on your own secluded islet
spend an afternoon at the Bora Bora
Yacht Club where you can feast on fine
cuisine in a pristine setting all right
Bora Bora I want to go to Bora Bora and
not Park City Utah you might rethink
that
I think Utah's
pretty I've actually never been but I
would rather you really never been
really never I want to take you to Utah
I want to take you in a camper van and
we'll just drive through you time so see
that's the kind of stuff that I would be
down to that we can go to Zion and we
find me Moab and we can go look at all
the stars I'm in the woods and I don't
have to see anybody like I really like
that anyway I'm I'm a tree person okay
are you ever just a tree person
sometimes yeah I just I feel much more
comfortable if what you're wearing
doesn't matter and everything just
doesn't matter I agree I'm much more
likely to be relaxed I agree even one
note that we made after our last
vacation if you say the resort was next
time we're maybe gonna stay somewhere
like more private like a little air
being me or something cuz it did feel
sometimes like people are getting
dressed up to go to breakfast and we're
just like we want to wear our [ __ ] I
want to look like a mess I'm on vacation
not that I don't look like a mess as it
is all day every day but like you know I
want to continue that streak of hard
work I have going for me yeah anyway the
only alcohol you're allowed to consume
at Park City I'll go with Park City
first is ski shots not near beer know
every every alcohol has to be drink in a
ski shop you know ski shadows know it's
when a ski like that you ski with yeah
has glued shot glasses on it yeah
there's a line of people that stand
there and go like this I didn't think it
was called a ski shot I think it is
anyway water soda liquor wine all have
to be consumed in ski shots okay the
stone massage is given to you by Nic
Cage okay I would let him touch me
platonically on the back and the
world-famous shopping at historic Main
Street is over one is overrun with rats
I don't mind rats me neither so I'm
trying to make parks any more appealing
here okay
bora-bora what did you do at night the
water turns in lava okay this is a
Minecraft pretty much yeah who's your
gear if you fall into it you die if you
want the whole water turns into lava
tonight
the only way to go to the bathroom ever
is to scuba dive to the bottom of the
water okay and use the underwater
port-a-potty I don't make the rules
except I make the rules if you have to
go to the bathroom at night then you
just got a scuba dive through the lava
into the port it tells you there's a
special portal where you can go just to
the Porta Potty all right I can amend
that how about this
in order to pee you have to pee in the
water so you have to jump inside you
know you you can't get you can't get
your business done without getting wet
okay you have to jump in the water to
pee right underneath your hat cool and
poop and last but not least your there
at the same time as a beauty influencer
brand retreat who's on the brain retreat
though it is anyone I know any of my
friends just all the video they have
like booked all of the cool spots on
wherever you're staying and they're
having parties every night yeah and you
can't go and they're all vlogging oh I'm
going to Park City Utah I scared you
away from Bora Bora oh no that's so sad
all right Chang right Island versus
Irvington Virginia is next go to
Thailand
tucked far in the north of the country
Chiang Rai offers a true get away from
the daily grind remote lush and unique
this place is made for those who want a
singular experience stay at the Four
Seasons tented camp Golden Triangle why
do we have to stay at the Four Seasons
where you can meet elephants explore
leafy jungles and survey the land from a
deck hot tub of your elevated luxury
tent indulge in a massage in an open-air
treatment room don't schedule a private
yoga class at the spa visit various
tents throughout the property for meals
with new friends and fellow guests or
head to the wine cellar for a private
dining party if the surrounding flora
has you desiring another kind of green
head to nearby water for
Valley Golf Club I thought I was gonna
advertise weed for a day on the links
often well yoga apparently are
everywhere on vacation people ever just
like to like sleep in and know they have
a tee time doing nothing
Erving Tanvir jigna I'm most sleep
through that [ __ ] tee time waterfront
charm and small town home eNOS make
Irvington an inviting escape Virginia's
pretty sailing golfing wine-tasting and
picnicking in the park are all on par
all par for the course in this historic
village though small it packs a punch
when it comes to the finer things in
life stay at the tides in we're deep
soaking tubs a secluded marina refined
dining in a therapeutic spa all on hand
to melt your worries away walk into town
for some shopping find new adornment for
yourself or at home objects art or more
pick up a gift or dinner pick up a gift
or or dinner we're at the dandelion
that's weird
now that you've got duds what it does
was that things now that you got the
duds head back to your digs why is she
running like this for dinner at the
on-site Chesapeake restaurant for the
best meal in Irvington ok Chiang Rai
first so you know how they said you're
staying at the Four Seasons it's now the
five seasons you can ask me what the
fifth season is what's the floud the
private yoga class is super private and
personal but also anyone can join for
free and it's required to attend by
anyone who wants to eat free breakfast
buffet ok the wine cellar has a one-way
door oh my god so you can never get out
well you can just can't use the door how
do you get out dig your way out
something ok like a rat ok that sounds
pretty nice have some pad thai just
won't go to the wine cellar
and I won't go to the yoga well it's
private and very secluded but everyone
who wants you to the breakfast buffet
must be I don't want to eat in the
breakfast buffet but you were required
to go to yoga class you have a tee time
of the yoga class I do not have a tee
time at the yoga class maybe one no okay
Irving ttan the whole entire resort is
one big escape room okay I've never done
this scape room so I'd be down below
vacation you're just trying to escape
I'd be down for at least the first
couple days hoping every staff member is
cosplaying as Colonel Sanders don't mind
that I will never break character okay
it's the same as saying that every staff
member that other hotel is a horse I
feel like I could work around okay fine
they have a VR television viewing
experience in your hotel but you can
only watch The Big Bang Theory with
Morse code narration as the audio track
if you look anyone up if you look anyone
in the eyes you'll get kicked out don't
make eye contact
not nerving ten you won't so just
picture VR experience of Big Bang Theory
and all you hear is the good bit but the
laugh track is still there
thoughts initial reaction let's go to
Thailand really yeah okay even though
the fifth season is loud even though the
fifth season is loud okay I don't want
to be in a place where I'm gonna get
kicked out if I make eye contact with
someone just wear sunglasses then they
can't tell work around but they don't
really want to go to either of them well
you have to so all right I'd still
rather go to tyler's so everything
No so I'll see you at everything you you
can go to Irvington okay well I'm glad
you chose Thailand because I'll be in
Irvington so GG's well we're not going
to any of these places because we're
stuck at home so anyway it reminds me
that there's no place like home and I
sometimes would just rather stay here
well maybe that's that was the goal is
to as much as we want to all be on
vacation
sometimes you get that we're lucky to be
at home we are lucky to be at home I
hope you enjoyed the game I put together
but anyway that's it I wouldn't mind
going to hotel where all the people
there are horses though how would be
good it would smell awful but it would
be good thanks for listening and joining
us on this escape from our reality two
luscious vacation luscious Julie
luscious and extravagant just wants to
go skiing I hope she Expedia for giving
us an article about skiing that poor
woman just wants to ski really bad
mm-hmm well hopefully I mean this was
written in 2017 hopefully she's you know
gone down the slopes a few times at
least since then
I hope so anyway
we'll be back next week with another
podcast I hope you guys enjoyed choose
your vacation if you didn't it's
Kermit's fault Oh blame Kermit and hope
you guys are all staying safe and
keeping it together not losing your mind
while stuck at home but we appreciate
you guys joining us and we'll see you
next week for another
[Music]